Welcome back everyone this is my doctor strange 2
video for some of the other hidden easter eggs and
deleted scenes that they revealed during the bonus
features in the commentary for the movie this one
mostly focusing on the alternate universes they
featured in the movie there are a lot of them
but one of them being an iron man themed universe
like if he'd completely taken over an entire
alternate universe version of earth so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of cool easter
eggs if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're also doing a
giveaway for thor love and thunder imax tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just post all your favorite moments from the
movie on the video but now the doctor strange two
has come out on digital and we can freeze frame
like every single frame and do all the zooming
and enhancing that you could possibly think of
doing some of you may have spotted some new easter
eggs during the movie when they feature a bunch of
alternate universes in rapid succession the scene
is specifically meant to have a bunch of easter
eggs and set up a whole bunch of really cool stuff
so there are a bunch of different universes
there sam raimi the director and the writer
have since confirmed in their commentary with
some of the bigger easter eggs were meant to be
i've already done a couple videos about some of
these easter eggs there's like a billion things
going on during this one little part of the movie
here so i'm mostly going to focus on the cool iron
man universe first then i'll cover some of the
other cool ones too and the stuff that they set up
so when doctor strange grabs america chavez
to save her from scarlet witch getting her
power sucked away they're falling through all
the different universes one of the universes
is basically an iron man universe you
notice there are pipes covering all the
buildings everything is all white black clean
looking powered by this greenish bluish energy
and you have all these stark industries drones
flying around them these are meant to be the same
stark industries drones from the edith that iron
man created we saw in spider-man far from home
and we saw the drones again being used by damage
control during the miss marvel series so while
the energy you see arcing all over the place is
literally meant to be his arc reactor infinity
stone based energy remember the element that he
created for that was based on the tesseract so
it's basically him powering all of his gear with
infinity stone based energy but this is supposed
to be like a superior iron man universe where his
original plan all the way back from avengers age
of ultron to cover the world in a suit of armor
literally became a thing like a universe where
his ideas and his worst fears completely won out
so it's a bit of a cool thing but also kind of
sinister at the same time like it's not all good
what if the lord was safe what if next time aliens
roll up to the club and they will they couldn't
get past the bouncer the only people threatening
the planet would be people i don't want to
hear the man was not meant to meddle medley
i see a suit of armor around the world sounds like
a cold world tony they had that whole thing during
avengers age of ultron where iron man tells them
about his fears and his plan like ah we can save
the world by completely over protecting it captain
america the other avengers kind of take him to
task over that over his paranoia tell him he's
basically being crazy like taking over the planet
and wrapping it in a suit of armor would not solve
all of the world's problems basically it would be
like iron man going full minority report turning
the world into a police state that's kind of the
way they're using his drones with damage control
during the miss marvel series where they just jump
on every single little thing that was also kind
of what mysterio had eventually planned to use
the stark industry's drones for so it just sounds
like in this universe the other avengers either
just went along with iron man's plan or whatever
the superior iron man wound up becoming or they
weren't able to stop him from going full superior
iron man if you're not a big comic book reader
superior iron man is sort of like the sinister
version of the character that gives into all his
worst instincts and addictions and basically tries
to solve everything with technology and it's like
the worst possible outcome for that character like
he doesn't turn into an outright villain but he's
very villainous there was a lot of talk about what
happened to the version of iron man who would have
been on the 838 universe illuminati team i did a
deleted scenes video so i'll also link that in the
description below he would have been a superior
iron man version of the character like a more
sinister version in the same tone as the rest
of the team because that was kind of the vibe
of their whole team like all the members of the
universe had done a bunch of really shady stuff
they'd all come together to make really shady
decisions but thinking that it was for the greater
good like they start off by basically telling
our doctor strange from the 616 universe that
they're gonna kill him because he's a greater
threat to the universe than he is of benefit
and they revealed that they killed their doctor
strange because he started to go off the rails
if they figured the universe would be better off
without him than with him just lying to the entire
planet just telling them that he was a hero no
no he died fighting thanos he's totally a hero
we totally didn't get rid of him just to
get rid of this problem in the future that
we think is going to happen so imagine a version
of that universe but where iron man did all that
stuff on his own made all those decisions on his
own basically and it was his solutions that won
out so ultimately iron man wound up taking over
that entire earth in that universe that's why
you see stark industries tech all over the place
and if it wasn't clear all these scenes are meant
to be happening in a similar location in these
different universes like these are all alternate
universe versions of this new york city area that
they're falling through the reason why some of
the universes are underwater or in the future or
seemingly in the past or there's no city at all
volcanoes lava flows is because in each universe
life on earth evolved in a slightly different way
in slightly different time periods and then later
on in the timeline you just have the butterfly
effect where that causes greater changes the
writer michael waldron was also the head writer
on the loki series so he has a lot of experience
in doing all these alternate universe easter eggs
he also confirmed one of the coolest theories that
everybody had so when they traveled through this
prehistoric universal the dinosaurs in the
background it is meant to be the savage land
from the x-men comics there are a lot of you that
have this theory so if you're not a big comic book
reader the savage land is a huge deep cut from
the x-men mythology they featured it a lot during
x-men the animated series back in the 90s they're
also bringing that series back for another season
next year on disney plus i don't know what they're
going to be featuring in all those episodes but
it'll be like a whole brand new season they're
just calling that x-men 97 because 97 is the last
year that it aired but here's a cool connection
between the savage land and everything that's
happening with the incursions and secret wars
the savage land was originally created by the
beyonders who ordered another alien to create
it to allow them to study human evolution the
beyonders are like this extra dimensional race of
beings who are so powerful that they're capable of
killing really high order cosmic beings like the
living tribunal which is also featured with them
passing through all these different universes
so when they ordered the savage land be built
it was built in this protected area of antarctica
hidden from the rest of the world in ancient times
kind of protected from the changes to the rest
of the planet in over time different groups from
the comics had visited it there was a group of
eternals that lived there tens of thousands of
years ago i was a slightly different backstory
in the mcu movies because the eternals that
we know didn't come to earth till about 7 000
years ago but in the recent history of comics
in the more present day the x-men have a lot of
adventures there with other mutants but in this
particular universe apparently this is a version
of the savage land that the beyonders had created
in the new york city area instead of antarctica
now sam raimi and the writer didn't say anything
specifically about the beyonders themselves so i
think this easter egg isn't meant to necessarily
canonize the beyonders to the mcu or anything
like that you can theorize who actually created
this version of the savage land but it is meant to
be the savage land the connection to secret wars
and the incursions is that in the comics the more
recent version of secret wars was caused by the
beyonders trying to destroy the multiverse they
were the ones that were causing the different
universes to collide with each other the mcu
version seems like it's going to turn more on
versions of kang the conqueror fighting their
kang multiverse war but the way they explain it
during doctor strange 2 is that different things
can cause incursions like it's not just the kang
multiverse war for instance reed richards of
the fantastic four blames our doctor strange for
everything that he's been doing recently with
the multiverse the spell that he performed in
spider-man their way home everything that scarlet
witch is doing saying that it's destabilizing
the barrier between universes leading to more
incursions happening we'll probably see other
marvel characters do really terrible things
to mess up and cause more incursions in other
future movies so it's not just going to be a
couple characters responsible for everything
whoops destroyed another universe i've already
talked about most of the other universes in my
separate video about this part of the movie like
the spider-man 2099 universe the loki universe the
paint themed universe the cree universe so i will
link that video below in the description but some
of the new easter eggs that we learned about from
the commentary is specifically are this black and
white universe was actually meant to be a hydra
universe now that we have a high-res version of
the scene you can actually zoom in enhance you see
the hydra symbol on the blimp in the background
so it's just meant to be a universe where it's
still the 1940s like it said in the past and
red skull has been successful in taking over the
world during world war ii the other really cool
easter egg here one of my favorite ones is the
hell universe you see an entire landscape in new
york city completely overrun with dead bodies fire
skeletons everywhere it's basically meant to be a
universe where mephisto conquered the universe in
the main mcu dimension which is absorbed into the
hell dimension it's kind of like what dormammu was
trying to do with his dark dimension absorbing the
main mcu dimension into it only now they're
just doing it with hell they use the moonite
series to explain how life after death works and
what happens to characters when they die your
consciousness basically transfers to an alternate
dimension in the place you go is based on your
belief system or if you have any contracts with
higher level celestial beings or gods like moon
knight is jewish so normally he go to the jewish
version of the afterlife but because mark specter
formed a contract with konchu part of the egyptian
pantheon of gods when he died again or every time
he died after that he go to the duat the egyptian
version of the underworld even though he didn't
believe in that for example thor odin hella as
guardians would either go to valhalla or their
version of hell which is called hell h-e-l in the
comics hella is actually the ruler of their hell
dimension when thor is talking to odin during thor
ragnarok talking about how he's not strong enough
and he makes that joke about him being the god of
hammers that's him talking to a version of odin's
consciousness which is in valhalla like they're
in valhalla during this scene here but the really
cool thing that's going on here in this easter
egg this version of hell existing on earth in this
universe is them laying the groundwork for how
ghost writer johnny blaze and the other characters
even mephisto characters that are part of that
mythology exist in the movies now like they're
canonizing all that stuff there are a couple other
big deleted scenes and easter egg videos that i'm
working on a couple other cool trailers that will
drop this week so make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of that all my
thor love and thunder easter egg post credit scene
videos all that stuff will start posting next week
after the movie comes out i believe i'm allowed to
post my thor love and thunder review next tuesday
so it'll still be a little while before that post
everyone click here to learn about that doctor
strange 2 doctor doom easter egg and deleted
scenes and click here for my new thor love
and thunder trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!